[Music]
remember so you don't have to every once
in a while you just got to relive a
classic game and for us that game is
doomed one of the best first-person
shooters ever do premiered in 1993
following a lone Space Marine on Mars
who has to fight off demons from heaven
it's as bare-bones bloody as it gets and
it kicks ass to revisit it again and
it's about to get a whole lot better
what you got there devil horn doom the
movie the game is it a god it has to be
the movie had the rock and r-rating and
rapid gunfire who the three sacred ours
did you ever see it no but a friend of a
friend of a friend of a friend of a
friend of a friend aid and he didn't
like it but it's the game version what's
this grew up did you ever play Street
Fighter the movies again no but a friend
of a friend of a friend put it in let's
kill some hell demon
[Music]
there doesn't seem to be a whole lot of
monsters maybe there would if they would
just turn the damn lights on I said it
not very eventful back to walking
you know you think the forces the hell
would have a little bit more variety in
their offense they do sure
I can't you're supposed to ask her
questions I think it's more of a mystery
than a shoot above anyone notice doom
the movie the game kind of sucks we'll
ask her well the hell spawn is there are
no Hell spawn here hell is a metaphor
for our current predicament but we do
have zombies
that's kind of cool shoot the dead
people so they don't come back to life
so you're supposed to shoot not moving
people they're already dead
even Jesus couldn't heal how lame this
is wait there's the rock I am turning
into an evil demon ah now we're talking
there I'm an evil demon now what the
hell this is supposed to be red meat Chu
and mayhem tell me the movie isn't this
doll
alright the movie isn't this doll okay
it's even though
and the continuing pattern of video game
movies sucking pixel ass do should have
been the easiest crowd-pleaser to make
you got the rock Gore and the premise
about shooting demons from hell on Mars
you have to try to make this
uninteresting but oddly enough we got an
adaptation that's both not faithful
enough and yet somehow to faith it's an
intriguing disaster that deserves to be
explored so let's see why do means dumb
this is would you like to use the BFG
yeah you may fire it twice at a wall and
then never again do weirdly it prolongs
the universal logo to give us this
incredibly important information
archaeologists working in the Nevada
desert discovered a portal to an ancient
city on Mars we're still struggling to
understand why it was built
would it have something to do with the
spice okay was that essential to put
before the studio ID it's like starting
off Jurassic Park with Dinosaurs our
thing
I'm not kidding what the Wraith are
going they might do that we start out on
Mars and so far it seems on the right
path with scientists running from some
sort of evil presence
[Music]
now whose regrets taking the last donut
this morning how are you gonna screw
this up this is like the perfect opening
to a doom film such a comment justified
reset Olduvai id 6 6 to 17 I fear I made
a game where the movie event horizon
will be a better adaptation we cut the
earth where the rock plays a Space
Marine whose still built even the camera
seems to get lost in his packs property
maintain quarantine at both Ark portals
by any means necessary
Christ I think the camera is fogging up
from the heavy breathing that camera
operator is giving actually who was the
camera operator on this you sneak on set
to get footage of a celebrity that
you're stalking and they credit you we
seized crew Marines who are totally
gonna live long lives oh they partake in
the most advanced a futuristic handheld
gaming Tiger electronics don't bother me
man I'm playing doc goes up and down on
90 cell phone you know movies in trouble
Wentz based on a game and they can't get
games right listen up man leave is
canceled got a problem with that Duke he
saw us he'll know I love my job but I
was just five seconds away from
retirement
that's literally retirement right there
coming towards me with my future
beautiful wife and kids oh I guess one
more mission is gonna kill me I mean is
gonna kill me I mean why can't I say the
word isn't he's joined by soldier John
Grimm played by Karl Urban what
knowledge is his sister is on the Mars
station that they're heading towards how
long's it been 10 years sure she's even
still up there
it's not that he's just terrified of
space travel remember a tiny crack in
the hull in our blood boils in 13
seconds I may throw up on you
jokes on Judge Dredd almir and skirts be
ready
you could be needed at any time I guess
you gotta face your demons sometime
that's dooms idea symbolism huh you know
it was gonna be followed up with I think
we should be more environmentally safe
I'm just feeling so down afraid I might
chicken out can this thing go to
ludicrous speed they do they're
expendable pose and go inside the mat
facility uaq that's the sound bite you
Billy makes when he dies so it turns out
the portal to Mars is the exact same as
Galaxy Quest cartoon splooge consuming
you and physically throwing you to
another planet get word of advice if you
can see the great kazoo traveling the
same way it's probably not gonna be
taken that seriously and here we are
Mars looks exactly like the set we were
just on like no difference by god you
change the light bulbs and suddenly you
travel through space ooh let me show you
my rocket ship I'm in space but it looks
like not everyone who used the portal or
Ark travel as they call it have a
successful ride in the past he went to
one galaxy his ass went to enough
unbelievable as it may seem
UAC does make the odd a tiny mistake how
didn't nobody make a Uranus joke you're
so bad it's good writing card please
they quarantined the area which
apparently means creeper immunity is
temporarily lowered 100 level 5
quarantine so I am just gonna have to
strip search you girl's rapist they come
across dr. Grimm who was assigned to
retrieve data from her lab we really
don't have room for passengers I have
orders to retrieve data from three
servers this is a military operation
doctor we're really not here to retrieve
your sign someone listened to my
eyebrows they know what they're talking
about just gonna spoil my day no
sir tell me you didn't let a
fine-looking piece of ass like that get
away from you Reaper
I know he's talking about her but his
eyes are on the rock tell me you didn't
let a fine-looking piece of ass like
that get away from you Reaper she's my
sister no shit
the Roxie assistant do you think you
know a woman so I'll give credit they
get to the gun hunting pretty fast again
making you think they're gonna just jump
right into the action and gore but it
might be hard to see yes apparently this
lab doesn't believe in any goddamn
lights and no it's not that they're out
there are literally no lights to be
found anywhere why do scientists and
movies never want to see their science
meanwhile John Haynes with his sister so
they can pointlessly bicker like well
whiny siblings oh yeah meet Lucy Lucy
this is my brother John another creature
from the long-lost past thanks for
protecting me while I do my research ass
this is Lucy's chromosome profile my
molecular genetics is a little rusty
what's the first thing dad taught us to
look for his beer never bother you you
could have spent your life looking in a
microscope instead of a sniper scope I
don't even get why they hate each other
this is the back story were given a
purse parents are the first team of
archaeologists to Olduvai they died in
some accident when he was a kid she
followed in their footsteps and he
didn't bad so why does that mean they
attack each other every other second
their parents are dead but they're both
doing honorable work maybe they're in a
contest or who can do the most awkward
American accent you got 24 pairs of
chromosomes we found no genetic
disorders no viruses no cancers so what
they were just naturally superior see
the earliest remains we found only had
23 we're bloody brilliant Americans we
ours bioengineering again thanks for the
protection dick okay the music's amped
up now we're getting some action
but the doors been read that way sir
there's something in Carmack's office
yeah thank the giant hold on the metal
door draws that conclusion quite clearly
you dumbass Oh newt is not aged well got
a car Mike it's me Samantha come on guys
give him a hand no regrets they
recognized him as the doctor but he's
clearly not well Mike Tyson in himself
tears off his own here shit like that
gets under your skin oh god I love those
Marines that undermine one another do
you heaven I'm just a little shocked if
I need something in my focus oh and get
high mid-mission I took his name in vain
oh and reacted taking the Lord's name in
vain by carving the Lord's name in vain
Joe had a more balanced army okay did
they find the others not yet my
husband's with them I'm sure Steve's
fine who Steve who are you maybe this is
Steve maybe he'll finally give us some
good acting he's dead all right there's
something in the vents that has to lead
to some badass violence monkey
was that the monkey they even tried to
take something so obviously lame and try
to make it sound intimidating what was
that monkey he took me through his
monkey rap once again something moves
they shoot and rock music comes back for
a couple seconds before turning
completely off once again that didn't go
the shit so let's come back to the
scientist where I don't know we're
supposed to care about go be with your
daughter don't want to stay Steve's
gonna be okay the guy's looking for me
the best that's right the pervy drug
taking cross carving best are you high
what you know you should go just to get
away from them
the van Gogh inspired doctor disappears
while our Marines continue to search for
friggin anything all right here we go
what the hell happened fell in the damn
hole everybody on me watch your goddamn
footing we opposed watch your goddamn
footing finally they come across
something supernatural hey Georgie but
again the action is friggin short as it
just takes a bite out of cross cutter
and they lose him in the lab where the
hell's Carmack
he disappeared what do you mean he
disappeared well I was gonna radio you
guys to let you know but things actually
the fine thing is people are getting
worse with the virus the scientist seems
to be getting worse with her acting she
slowly starts to slump in some very odd
line delivery god help us like the gamut
between extreme reaction absolute
nothing and only a second oh god oh god
good lead in delivery wasn't that great
either you were gonna tell me just what
the fuck is going on up here
what spoken like a degree carrying
professional what hey what duh what blah
well the soldiers search for answers the
scientist is left behind with her bubble
wrap door Dook Dook
it's just a power source on constant
badass firing have anything but stupid
fake cows and lame short jump scares
damn straight
and we're getting sick of it we're gonna
shoot the shit out of this movie and
it's spin-off game let's kill drug guy
who's carving crosses into his arm go
ahead sir yeah we're coming safe with
you here yeah he'll be okay this is very
exciting though and it's like 19%
exciting on Rotten Tomatoes
oh just the cameraman sorry
dude gets attacked by Pumpkinhead
covered in pasta but they stop into the
bubble-wrap door thank you for saving me
cock woo this window contains a
flashback could you keep your backstory
down I'm going over my lines from my
Hannah Montana cameo I can't be doing
some weird shit in case you're wondering
by the way this backstory goes nowhere
yeah it's like focusing on Batman being
allergic to cats
ah yes it's kind of interesting but it
doesn't further a goddamn thing so they
keep searching through somebody make
that cannon so they keep searching
through the labs and again come across a
threat that just quickly runs away
moving fast thank you what do you see
it's big very big moving fast
lord knows numbers aren't used by the
military or scientists to describe how
big or fast something is it's big very
big but there's another big thing even
bigger than the last big thing my god a
big thing even bigger than the big thing
that was bigger than the other big thing
big surprise is more exact than you but
it looks like the cross cutter from
before is not quite dead set
my god I'm so religious I'm Jesus and
again just when you think a cool action
scene might take this guy out he takes
his own 4 against ofout knew he was
turning so yes you probably realized by
now this is just a lame-ass zombie film
that's more shame to use the word zombie
than the walking dead regardless they do
at least try to work in a weapon from
the game one of the most famous guns of
all time The BFG oh yeah they know to
build this shit up The BFG is such a
testosterone enhancer every gun starts
to look like a dick you're a lucky
person if you find someone who looks at
you the way the rock looks at the BFG
it's badass
it fires awesome and as we all know BF G
stands for bio force shut up shut up
you're an r-rated movie help you can get
away with saying it even once in a pg-13
movie
and you go with that shit are you
kidding me next you'll be telling me
STFU stairs are silly Teletubbies find
unicorns I should not have to tell doom
to grow a pair but screw it if it gets
the job done it gets the job done after
two more men are killed in the dark
where we can't see a damn thing
Rock comes in with the bio-forge gun to
take care of business
[Applause]
hmm that guy's dying I guess I'm a crazy
character or something and okay look
cool but it was one shot and I don't
even think he got the thing is that it
is that it for a while
really so um not to ruin the dumpster
fire of surprises that I'm sure are
ahead of us but uh how many more times
does he use that gun in this friendly
giant it'd be about as intimidating
I bet the jackasses who wrote this are
the same jack ancestors thought this is
the most six earthbenders to do help
they both have rocks in them with no
personality
to Frank and Claire oh my god not again
I got okay so Rock drops off two more
dead bodies and once again tries to get
some answers what are you people
experimenting with up here I told you
it's an archeological research center
I'm on a diplomatic mission to Alderaan
shithead and like I said the scientist
acting seems to get squeakier and
squeakier what will you send to protect
the research data tell me about this
human emotion called human emotion it
looks like they were experimenting on
criminals and now the experiments have
gotten out of control we were never
gonna do human studies chromosome 24 I'm
in a movie if he perfected xenogenesis
don't you get it it's this place it's
hell it always was
oh yeah you heard that correctly this is
held as in symbolically hell that's what
we want to see in a doom movie a place
so crazy reminds people of Hell but not
really hell just like hell it's
practically the same thing this is the
equivalent of telling your children hey
kids we're going to Disneyland
that is I'm gonna smack you on the head
until you
cartoon mice and stars to wish upon but
it's like Disney laugh I nailed this you
call if you need help okay
thank you again twat no I do hope
there's rock music that starts up and
instantly disappears
go through this movie has so little
action the rock music is actually useful
running not fighting running whenever
they run that's when the music comes in
how pathetic is that for a dual movie
look there's the monster let's get him
home wait no it's just my own projected
sense of self-worth symbolic hello but
one other monster seems to have gone
through the portal back to earth so they
have to return to yeah you guessed it
the exact same set to look over the
damage because they know that Dead come
back to life they spend most of their
time excitingly shooting already dead
people okay did a robot write and say
your lines how come these two are never
in the same room they discover a room of
families still alive but the rock
doesn't want to take the chance and says
kill them all well they're okay they're
just scared shitless
we'd kill them all I think son you don't
think my God sort him out okay okay look
um I'm actually open to the idea of the
rock playing the villain in something
but doom the movie where he holds the
BFG is the focus of the poster and it -
this is the one you want to try that out
with okay look rocket you're a badass
and everything don't get me wrong but
you're also kind of adorable now he's
doing the eyebrows they go and that's so
menacing it
Yunis insurrection is punishable by
death em okay this is apparently what we
wanted I don't need anybody else but
soldiers let's um look at the scale of
how much that was aren t I pretty well
could you tell me what the point of my
drug subplot was more zombie not held
demon whatever his attack and the market
spot among them he calls bullshit on
what they're doing with him I mean did
any of you read the manual about how to
use your rock I don't die I'm not boring
it weirdly enough I don't kill kids it's
up to plan dipper and Mabel now just
listen to her emotional concerns
don't say with me let's do it trying to
stay with me you're bleeding to death
so this is our Dorothy right we just may
want to act in movies and that we
learned our lesson she gives him the
disease because apparently if you have a
good soul it'll make you super strong
and not corrupting yes science it seems
to work though as for a movie that tried
so little to be like doom it's suddenly
over corrects and goes to a first-person
point of view trying to look exactly
like the game to a ridiculous degree
okay somewhere in between nothing like
the damn game and just the damn game
there's a damn movie please give us a
damn movie but again because it's not
actually hell he's just shooting zombie
scientists look that was the wheelchair
guy so any time you saw a monster that
looks like him in the game that was
always meant to be the same wheelchair
guy all of them they're all this
wheelchair guy was that guys planted
Sharman to death you can't resist my
smile asshole Wow it's just like the
game except I can't control anything and
the story's completely different but you
gem saying truly outrageous suddenly
makes this authentic we got this he
comes across the rock who is of course
infected but he tells him he has one
last round in the BFG left I've got one
round well they better make it goddamn
cow just call this a prequel to Roger
Rabbit it makes no sense but it's a more
satisfying connection to to the game
thank you the fist fight because again
Doom is really known for its fist fights
but at the very least they can give us a
big ass crazy monster version of the
rock you know maybe one of these guys or
something you can have fun with this
idea what's his final form
oh you just change design color and
teeth that is exactly what I imagine the
final boss and doom would look like oh
we're rock are you really gonna have me
say something positive about this I
really don't want to say anything
positive about this he throws him in the
portal back to Mars and sends a grenade
with him go to hell
hello hard nosed this movie isn't
willing to do so he grabs his sister and
heads back to the surface of Earth
almost almost completely missed the mark
tomato tomahto
and that was doom or so they tell me you
would never guess by watching it I guess
to its credit they get a few details
right like the backstory in the game is
about a Space Marine disagreeing with
his surgeon because the sergeant wanted
to murder the innocent and there was a
portal to Mars as well as scientist
doing evil experiments but taking a hell
out of the equation is like taking ducks
out of duck tails it's a friggin big
part as an adaptation that goes from
unfaithful to to faithful and as a
standalone movie it's just a generic and
forgettable flaw there's not much
character there's not much gore there's
just not much do and if there's anything
dooms shouldn't be
it's friggin Borg now I'm not gonna stop
until we pay the doom game the respect
it deserves we're gonna wipe out
everything associated that dumbass movie
you in
[Music]
Dunley you magnificent bastard this
thing came off you really ruined our
groove here okay give me a minute you
said a second it's a minute now no no
okay doesn't really stay on back let's
roll
there's that awful movie
there's the game based on the movie
based on the game
there's that piece-of-shit script for
the film
hi I am Chris Geller I was the dental
technician in the movie
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and doom should
never don't
[Music]
[Applause]
I fell in the damn hole
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing in
gender health and gender health works to
improve the health and well-being of
people in the poorest communities of the
world they do this by sharing their
expertise in sexual and reproductive
health and transforming the quality of
health care they promote gender equality
advocate for sound practices and
policies and inspire people to assert
their rights to better healthier lives
working in partnership with local
organizations they adapt their work in
response to local needs with more than
65 years experience in the field of
international sexual and reproductive
health in gender health currently
supports projects in dozens of countries
around the world if you look at their
site in their YouTube channel you'll
understand why they're the leading
global women's health organization
committed to working toward a world
where sexual and reproductive rights are
respected as human rights click on the
link and see what you can do to help so
many people have safe and wonderful
futures
[Music]
you